do not wait until 2024 to start these Health
hacks hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen nears is around the corner and I
know that for a lot of people this means
a lot of Extreme Weight Loss diets that get
abandoned by Valentine's Day as you guys know
I'm not a weight loss Rd but I do believe in
body Aton om and I respect those who want to
lose weight or who cite weight loss as their
nearest resolution and I would way rather see
people make more gentle evidence-based healthy
Behavior changes than start some kind of like
omad carnivore diet or cut out all fibers and
carbs and I also know that a lot of folks place
weight loss as their end goal but it's actually
not a good goal because it's not something that
we are 100% in control of our behaviors on the
other hand are controllable and predictable so so
I'm going to share some super tangible actionable
behaviors hacks and habits that you can integrate
today that increase your chances of weight loss
and improved overall health now quick note here
that not all of these tips are going to be good
habits for everyone for some people making one
of these swaps could feel super restrictive be
super triggering result in a rebound or just not
jive with their lifestyle preferences budget Etc
so take what works for you and leave the rest all
of these are suggestions for gent nutrition habits
to experiment with and of course don't forget to
hit on my description for my free Hunger crushing
combo ebook and I apologize for the voice my kids
gave me laryngitis again all right let's get
into it tip number one have protein at every
meal and most snacks protein is King in the
satiety hierarchy which is why it's at the
top of my HCC triangle we know how important
maintaining lean muscle masses for metabolism
weight management and Longevity as we age and as
I discussed in my macros video right here we also
know that focusing on protein is really important
when we're in a calorie deficit research suggests
that people spontaneously consumed 400 calories
less when their protein intake went from 15 to
30% of calories because we can only utilize about3
gram of protein per kilogram of body weight per
meal or snack for muscle protein synthesis one of
the most important habits that you can get into
today is prioritize protein at every meal ideally
around 20 to 35 gram per sitting adding protein
helps to provide longer lasting stable satiety
energy and blood sugar levels and increases the
chances of weight loss success without scarcity
or restriction tip two Implement a no phones at
Meal Time rule you guys know I don't normally
like rules but this is actually one that I can
get behind and I know it's a hard rule to follow
because I literally fail at this 50% of the time
but 50% success rate is like a huge win to me
they've done studies you know 60% of the time it
works every time that doesn't make sense we know
that distractions like phones tablets and TVs make
listening to our body's hunger and fullness cues
really hard research suggests that eating while on
your phone increases chloric consumption by about
15% largely because we aren't even registering
emotionally while we ate we're stripping food of
its sensual satisfaction and also interfering with
the social benefit of a family meal so no phones
at all at the dinner table they're either off or
away charging in another room where we're
not so tempted by the constant scrolling
and notifications tip three bulk cup and stretch
refined carbs with fiber rich FEG notice I said
bulk cup not cut down even though the result is
usually in fact cutting down so you know I've got
an additive approach to nutrition which is why I
like to stretch refined carbs by adding them into
a fiber rich veg so that may mean adding some
like zucchini ribbons to your pasta or adding
some finely diced veg to your rice not only does
this add another layer of flavor and texture but
it turns a low fiber lower nutrient meal into one
that is far more satiating and even if you don't
change the portion of rice that you put on your
plate at all there's a good chance you may not
need as much of it because the added fiber from
the veggies adds volume and promotes a TIY which
is important for weight management and this is a
another really key reason why my Hunger crushing
combo Works tip four choose fats with purpose
okay what do I mean by that well you guys know
that our hunger crushing combo combines protein
which we talked about fiber which we talked about
and healthy fats and I will never ever suggest
that you shouldn't use oils for cooking or in
salad dressing you should these make naturally
nourishing foods a lot more delicious but wherever
it makes sense I want you to choose whole food
fat sources that have like dual HCC citizenship
so that have fatten fiber or fat and protein
avocado is a really great example because it's
got 22 G of satiating fats 3 g of protein and has
a whopping 10 G of fiber each making it much more
satiating than an equivalent amount of fat in oil
likewise whole peanuts have 14 G of fats 7.5 g of
protein and 2.5 g of fiber so these Foods offer
more volume flavor and hunger crushing compounds
than straight up oils or fats so like you could
try using avocado as a sandwich spread or adding
nuts or nut butter as the base for salad dressings
and sauces tip five drink a big glass of water the
moment you get up and another one as your coffee
is brewing I have discussed this coffee thing ad
nauseum if you want to drink your coffee on an
empty stomach there's likely no real harm in doing
so assuming it doesn't upset your tummy or cause
you raging anxiety but you've just gone eight or
more hours without any hydration or nutrition so
you want to capitalize on that morning Thirst by
working water into your coffee ritual the moment
you wake up before you check your phone drink a
full glass of water and as your coffee is brewing
or you're making your tea or whatever your ritual
is drink another one another one another one
this is really really important for regularity
bloating weight management energy metabolism
cognitive performance and Joint AB ility tip six
use parental lock functions to limit your phone
use before bed yes I am suggesting that some of
us need to like parent ourselves a little to limit
our phone use before bed but let me tell you why
we know that screens before bed significantly
interfere with our circadian rhythms and sleep
and poor sleep impacts our appetite food cravings
blood sugars weight gain cognition and attention
immunity defenses and much more there are actual
like apps for Parental safeguard s and locks that
you can put into play to lock you out of social
media before after a certain time in the day and
if you're the type to like stay up late scrolling
resulting in really poor sleep it might be time
to use them Keeping Up with the Kardashians is
nowhere near as important as restorative sleep
and your resulting Health liar tip seven take
one call or virtual meeting every day while
walking exercise doesn't have to be intentional
or sweaty for it to count in fact you're actually
less likely to compensate by by rewarding yourself
with more food when movement is framed as fun or
leisurely than it is as exercise so if you have
to listen in on like a boring Zoom conference
call turn the camera off pop your airbuds in
and take it while Meandering around through
like a nearby residential area if you're waiting
on hold with like an airline or Bank do it in the
Great Outdoors yes the elevator music might kill
you inside but if you do survive you're going to
feel great thanks to the combination of fresh air
and gentle movement this is actually a bonus step
for my adhders but you actually might find that
you can concentrate much better at what's being
said while simultaneously moving your body and
the best part is this isn't eating into your
busy day tip eight buy a different fruit and veg
than you did the week before as you guys know I
am big on the importance of variety because a
vary diet is the most likely diet to meet all
of your nutrient needs our gut bacteria also
thrives on diet diversity but food right now
is expensive especially fresh fruits and veg
so most of us can't afford to eat like three
different fruits and three different vegetables
each day at every meal of the week so make an
intentional point to switch up which varieties you
buy from week to week if this week it's apples and
broccoli make next week kiwis and cauliflower
if this week you're making salads with spinach
next week Duke kale Etc this not only helps
prevent healthy eating recipe ruts reducing the
risk of you like throwing in the towel but it's a
foolproof way to ensure greater nutrient variety
over time and speaking of variety Plan Three
mindless breakfasts to rotate with different
variations unless you're a wellness influencer
no one actually has the mental energy to come
up with a fancy new breakfast recipe every day
of the week like mornings are hectic enough so
if breakfast takes too much mental bandwidth you
are much more likely to just like grab a crystal
or bacon sandwich on the go see tip one about
the importance of protein especially in that
morning meal re suggest that having a protein
Rich breakfast significantly reduces appetite
throughout the day and results in fewer calories
consumed at your next meal so I suggest having
three simple protein Rich breakfast Concepts that
you always have the ingredients for and you always
have like the time and energy to pull off and then
just adding in slight variations with different
toppings so my three are protein oatmeal protein
smoothie bowl and like a cottage cheese or yogurt
parfait and I switch things up every week with
different fruits nuts seeds berries cereals and
other crunchy toppings depending on my mood and on
the vibe of breakfast one of my personal favorite
tips is to mix high sugar cereal with a high fiber
whole grain cereal I do this all the time because
sometimes I just feel like a little Frosted Flake
action but I know that this isn't going to hold me
very long but I also know that I'm 36 years old
and starting my day with like a bowl of sugar
doesn't feel super great for me or for my gut so
rather than putting sugary cereal up on a pedestal
and telling myself I can never have it again which
we all know gives our friend Tony way too much
power I added to a bowl of high fiber cereal like
brand flakes or my morning oats oh I love a little
Lucky Charms moment on proin notes trust me
if you a sugary cereal lover this hack will
change your life tip 11 experiment with fruit as
a sweetener I'm never going to tell you not to
put honey in your oatmeal or to like make cookies
without sugar but don't underestimate the natural
sweetness of fruit ripe mashed banana is amazing
in oatmeal yogurt baked goods Etc and freeze dried
berries either like ground up or whole also adds
a ton of flavor antioxidants and natural sweetness
again this is all about an additive approach
to nutrition so by adding a ripe banana to
your oatmeal we not only are cutting back on the
need for a lot of brown sugar but we add volume
and add a ton of sating nutrition that keeps us
Fuller longer tip 12 drink two sips of water in
between every sip of alcohol I could and should do
a whole video on alcohol The Good the Bad and the
Ugly but again I will never tell you not to have
an occasional drink if that's what brings you Joy
like I will never tell myself that but drinking
too too much too fast is not only damaging to
our long-term Health but has immediate unpleasant
consequences alcohol affects quality sleep which
we already established is Bad News Bears it causes
constipation bloating dehydration puffiness and
other hangover symptoms we up it also lowers
inhibitions which increases the likelihood of
overeating and of course it adds excess calories
without providing much useful nutrition so we do
see an increased risk of obesity in heavy drinkers
so the new guidelines actually suggest limiting
alcohol to two drinks per week and if you drink
more than that to limit to no more than two drinks
per sitting to accomplish that and also to prevent
the dreaded hangover I suggest trying to take a
minimum of two big sips of water between each sip
of alcohol this will slow you down prevent overc
consumption and keep you hydrated to mitigate
some of the aftermath effects effects tip 13
when dining out if you can start with a vegetable
based appetizer or Salad yes there's a lot of
diet websites that will insist you like fill up
on a plain salad or broth-based soup before you
eat your Mane to reduce your calorie consumption
when dining out and honestly that suggestion is
actually evidence-based so research has found
that starting a meal with a salad reduces the
meal's caloric intake by 12% but this is not the
reason why I make this suggestion I make this
suggestion to a encourage more fiber intake which
is generally lacking in restaurant food and can
be super important to counteract the digestion
slowing effects of a lot of excess sugars fat
and alcohol and B prevent yourself from falling
into an all or nothing mentality when dining out
folks who have heavily restricted calories for
most of their life tend to get into like a Last
Supper mentality when they get off their diet in
a restaurant where they feel the need need to get
like the fried appetizer and the creamy cheesy
pasta and the bread and the cheesecake and the
bottle of wine because diet starts tomorrow folks
YOLO but by starting with something nutritious
like a salad you're automatically kicked out of
that All or Nothing trap and you can make more
balanced choices that actually feel good to your
body and still satisfy those Cravings tip 14 batch
prep meal building blocks not completed recipes
meal prep can be super helpful when you're trying
to Kickstart more healthy diet habits but one of
the biggest reasons why people don't stick to it
is that they get bloody bored of eating the same
meal pre lunch all week long I feel that if you're
not excited about your meal you're more likely to
accidentally leave it at home and buy something
on the go so I suggest making big batches of
meal components that can be reassembled into
a variety of different meals throughout the week
so grill a bunch of chicken breast or tofu cook
a big pot of quinoa or rice pan roast a couple
types of different veg and from there you can do
salads sandwiches soups stir fries bowls tacos and
more tip 15 put pre- prepped fruits and veggies
in clear glass containers our food choices often
come down to marketing and convenience so we kind
of have to be good marketers for nutritious
Foods one of my favorite ways to do this is
by spending about 30 minutes on a Sunday when I
get the groceries home to wash and prep all the
produce I put everything into clear containers so
that I can visually see what's in them and then
I pop them into the fridge at eye level not
hidden behind the milk or the leftovers it's
got to be front and center so when you get home
from a long day and you're ravenous and you will
eat whatever is convenient those pre- chopped
fruits and veggies will be like staring at you
as the most intuitive Easy Choice and finally
a little bonus tip here because I could not not
share this whenever you reheat your Le leftovers
whether they're homemade or they're from like a
restaurant throw a handful or two of spinach or
leafy greens with a pinch of salt into the bottom
of the bowl as your meal reheats it will Wilt the
greens and marinate them in whatever kind of like
sauce or seasoning your leftovers contain adding
more volume fiber and nutrients without any kind
of additional effort well folks that's all that I
have for you guys today I really hope that these
actionable gentle nutrition habits can replace
more like lofty abstract weight schools as we
go into a new New Year's resolution season
but I really hope you like this please give
us a thumbs up leave me a comment below if you
have any actionable healthy eating habits that
have really done wonders for you don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and check out my
Hunger crushing combo ebook in the description and
I'll see you next time on aby's kitchen [Music]
bye